bonsoir que blanche maison et vous
qu'est ce qui a poussé le président
russe à s'exprimer aujourd'hui sur la
crise des prix du gaz c'est un contexte
particulier à cela ça peut paraître
surprenant parce qu'effectivement tout
le monde sait depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines que une situation du
marché mondial du gaz naturel qui est
que la demande excède de beaucoup
l'offre et ceci parce que l'économie
reprend heureusement après la crise du
que vides notamment en asie spécialement
en chine et que donc à une demande très
forte et que les pays qui produisent ce
gaz le fournissent naturellement comme
comme comme d'habitude donc 7,7 tensions
existent aussi sur le pétrole d'ailleurs
à lorsque la lumière poutine a voulu
dire aujourd'hui c'est un la russie
respecte intégralement les contrats
qu'elle a signés est en effet une partie
de ce gaz est fourni sur à partir de
contrats à moyen ou long terme et il a
répété ce qui est exact que la russie
respecte à la lettre ces contrats que
peut-être les pays occidentaux et les
pays européens n'ont pas été très bien
inspiré de passer le plus possible en
dehors de ses contrats à long terme pour
acheter du gaz sur le marché au jour le
jour on appelle ça le marché spot à
rotterdam avec un prix qui s'établit au
jour le jour et effectivement il dit que
la russie serait prête à regarder le
sujet pour l'avenir et à conclure
davantage de contrats à long terme mais
effectivement l'esprit du temps le goût
de la commission pour la concurrence
pure et parfaite fait que les états
membres vont de plus en plus sert le
marché spot alors par ailleurs il a par
la même aussi indiqué que la
construction de structures fixes comme
les gazoducs par exemple vont plutôt
dans le sens de contrats à long terme
puisque ça a établi des relations
stables et prévisibles entre un
fournisseur et des clients il ya
évidemment aussi vous parler de l'air du
temps un média aussi certainement ces
tensions qui révèle peut-être des
divergences politiques et diplomatiques
dont on parle souvent évidemment sur ce
plateau peut-être plus profond de la
crise du gaz qui cristallise les
tensions entre l'union européenne et la
russie
sans doute une manifestation parmi
d'autres de cette situation politique
mais il faut quand même noter que le le
le parce que derrière cette affaire
naturellement tout le monde pense à la
sphère de nord stream de le le le
gazoduc north stream ii a été terminée
il a été acheté il est actuellement en
période de test en période d'essai et on
attend pour sa mise en service que le
régulateur allemand certifie la
conformité de cet équipement aux règles
qui sont les règles allemandes et
européennes est évidemment plus le
régulateur allemand attend plus il y
aura une tension effectivement sur le
marché allemand et par conséquent sur le
marché européen alors choix qu'il faut
aussi noter que dans le fond cette
affaire concerne au premier chef les
allemands puisque eux dépendent beaucoup
du gaz russe pour leur approvisionnement
en gaz mais aussi pour leur mix
énergétique la france 2 dépend cave 1 %
de la russie pour son approvisionnement
en gaz et comme on le sait à la par
ailleurs beaucoup d'autres sources
d'énergie notamment le nucléaire
l'allemagne sort du nucléaire et par
conséquent a besoin de recourir
davantage au gaz alors il ya aussi
peut-être une condition du côté de la
commission pour la mise en service
réelle de leur stream 2 c'est que la
commission à une directive déjà demain
peu en ciel qui indique qu' on ne peut
pas utiliser une infrastructure que ce
serait d'ailleurs une infrastructure de
transport de chemin de fer par exemple
avec un utilisateur qui aurait le
monopole de l'utilisation est en plus
une la propriété d'une partie de cette
infrastructure il faut séparer les deux
alors il faut espérer que la commission
n'insistera pas pour faire appliquer
cette directive et acceptera par
conséquent la vie dans la mise en
service rapide de nord stream 2 et
claude blanchemaison dernière question à
la proche de la coop 26 1 qui aura lieu
à glasgow la première quinzaine de
novembre continue aussi des impératifs
évidemment écologique est ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à une pression justement pour
ralentir la production et la
distribution de gaz je ne crois pas tous
les économistes
du secteur de l'est connaît de l'énergie
indiquent que la consommation de gaz et
par conséquent sa production va
augmenter il va augmenter encore pendant
quelques dizaines d'années parce que
comme je viens de le dire à l'instant
par exemple en europe l'allemagne
sortant du nucléaire elle a d'ailleurs
un peu recours au charbon un peu trop un
peu trop par rapport aux normes des
coptes successives et on va à la
rappeler à l'ordre sans doute aussi à la
coop 26 en 10 ans il faut pas recourir
davantage au charbon mais par contre le
gavage présentement inconvénients en
termes d'émissions de co2 donc le gaz a
encore un bel avenir devant lui même si
effectivement à terme est bien la
priorité ce sera d'aller vers des
économies le plus possible décarbonés de
produisant le moins possible de co2 si
possible pas de co2 du tout mais il faut
à chaque pays revoient sont mixtes
électrique puisque pour faire
d'électricité il faut évidemment une
énergie primaire et si l'énergie
primaire n'est pas nucléaire et ça ne
peut être que du désir au carbure ou
bien il faut recourir aux énergies
renouvelables qui pour le moment occupe
une place assez faible dans les mix
énergétique des différents états merci
beaucoup claude blanchemaison pour cet
éclairage